well I reached out to g nine million
times but writers know the greater the
writer is I think the more reclusive
they are and I really honored that you
know and you know that they just don't
want to present themselves and there we
go you know it's the writing it's the
power of the writing the words so I try
to present in a script and the words
that's that's I think the beauty and the
power of it that's that is fitted not
like for me to let me put you on video
you know let me ask his he interviewed
how many people like 500 of those those
little videos you know of strangers on
the street and I was like you know Raph
felt this video of the the quilt of all
these people that's your thing that's
your vision your voice your decision
that's not me you know because i have we
probably haven't gotten into a long
dialogue about it but I'm not one of
these people that believes that you
should forgive everything you know I I
don't you know what samuel goes through
is for him he has to forgive in order to
release the hatred I believe that you
can hold hold the anger and not be
hateful and not forgive you know and use
it in a powerful way but my character
doesn't and I didn't feel that I felt
that was his thing and you know I I just
um I don't know I I did this because I
thought it was so wonderful that you
responded to Rafael and that I wanted to
support him here you know and I loved
your your show and I just thought yeah
we're all kind of the same you know
we're all like trying and um yeah and
actually know the this whole theme of
forgiveness is that I mean I try to part
of the reason I went out to the streets
is to learn what it is because when you
really start thinking about it I mean I
don't know if people really think what
forgiveness really
you know although we'd have to deal with
it every day in our lives you realize
that it's a very complicated thing and
it's probably the most complicated thing
for for all of us you know and you know
and the answers we gather so complex and
in the end I think what I learned is
that there is no answer I don't know I
don't know there wasn't a comment and I
and I think well I mean there's always
new imaging is always like Wisconsin
yeah but that's not me let's forgive and
everything will be peaceful but the
reality is that it's it's a process it's
a very difficult thing and it's it's
complicated and you know sometimes we
you know people try to forget so they
can forgive but they really haven't
forgiven or they try to do it
symbolically you know generally everyone
kept on telling us that it's a healing
thing and we all know that that it's
very you can't carry this pain you know
that these characters are carrying that
we're all carrying but in the so part of
the process of making this video is just
to go out and just to hear a million
opinions you know and I feel as a
filmmaker it's not my duty to preach or
say what it is it just to throw things
out and let people discuss think just
like the script you know let people find
their own answers within the script
their own personal way of finding it and
maybe the world will it as well so when
I did this whole presentation I wasn't
going to be in it at all in fact I was I
didn't want to be in this video now I
mean I did this little this interview
that's part of it I mean they what I
talk in the video is that something that
shot like him 20 minutes one day one
morning when I just fell I got to say
something about it but the original
Kickstarter video is just everyone
talking about these themes of the movie
the drawings and the actors and then I
and then we say we decided that we're
going to do like a sister documentary to
help to drive the social media to drive
interest in the script and Kickstarter
in the last minute as we submitted the
project they said you know you can't
page two projects at once you have to
decide are you going to just the
documentary that's your research for the
movie and then
the movie all right is gonna do the
movie and and the whole reason why we
started this was for to make the movie
side then I said okay we're just going
to do the campaign for the movie and
then I had to redo the house video in
the last minute so in the end I got
stuck with being the present so I'm in
the video you know like it or not you
know I feel embarrassed about it tonight
no I I don't feel comfortable showing
myself no I think it's very important
yeah you're good at it have you received
feedback that they're glad that you're
in it that it really helps that one
person and and we know who we're
donating money yes and then who you are
we see you maybe we'll become then
familiar with certain things will try to
look up your other projects as i did
this morning and i'd like to see your
films yeah so hopefully hopefully see
what dr. scare people away yeah you know
i think also kick study such a young
thing you know everyone is so like hip
hip and cool in fact I'm even guilty of
it myself you know that I've supported a
lot of Kickstarter projects and they
were a couple where they'd such
wonderful charismatic and beautiful
people just presenting their projects
which I just my hardest opus gave the
money I don't even wanna wish I don't
even wanna find out what the project was
about I just love them you know so it's
very awkward enough for us you know who
are more seasoned you know filmmakers to
and you know and I hope Kickstarter want
to be limiting that it's a youth thing
you know they help people there's a lot
of older people who have loved to make
things and have things they would love
to share with the world but never got
the chance to and maybe it'll be their
opportunity also so it's not only chance
for young people to get their beginning
but a lot of it transferred some people
who struggle or all their lives to do
something never got the chance and maybe
now if the young people can embrace them
you know they'll get a chance to
you